The only people who now get married are
people who are relatively wealthy.
You know the fact that we've disrupted
the structure of marriage as an
institution since about 1965 say what
that's meant what that has meant is that
it's its benefits are now only available
to people who are privileged so you can
look up the Stout's yourself.
But if you're middle class and above the
divorce rates haven't moved much since
the early 70s if you're working class
and below it's a complete catastrophe.
And what that's meant is that most meant
many children who are in.
Rougher socioeconomic straits are being
raised by a single person who has
absolutely and 100 percent overwhelmed
by their multiple commitments right full
time responsibility for children and
generally in employment in
extraordinarily dismal low paying
unstable and exploitative job.
So to me if you if you're like you guys
are you're all going to be middle class
or above in all likelihood it's like
it's fine for you.
It's not going to make a bloody bit of
difference.
All things considered but for people who
are poor it's just been a catastrophe.
So.
Yes.
Oh well there's all sorts of reasons.
I mean first of all it's become socially
acceptable.
Right.
Divorce wasn't socially acceptable.
And you can say well that's that was
pretty hard on people who wanted to get
divorced.
It's like yeah obviously any rule is
hard on people that break it but that
doesn't mean that there shouldn't be
rules you know.
Now what rules there should be.
That's a whole different issue.
Out of wedlock child birth has become a
norm.
It was absolutely rare in the 90s in the
early 1960s vanishingly rare.
And that's become it's it's acceptable
even though all the evidence suggests
like if you actually look at the
evidence it's absolutely clear that kids
who have two parents do better than kids
who have one.
Now you know people when you tell people
that they'll tell you an anecdote about
someone they knew maybe their own parent
who did a wonderful job of raising them
as a single person.
It's like the anecdotes are irrelevant.
What's relevant is the bulk of the
evidence.
Of course there are situations where
people are better apart than together.
And of course there are situations where
one person can do a better job than two
people who are at each other's throats
but it's aggregate it's aggregating
examples that you use when you're doing
a scientific survey and the results of
those surveys are crystal clear.
You know the other thing that's going to
happen it's going to happen very soon is
that there is going to be a very very
very very large number of elderly
people.
Who are low and.
B and elderly and a loan like no family
that is not something you want to look
forward to especially when you start
thinking that you're going to be elderly
for like 40 years.
So you know because say say it starts
around 65.
I don't know how long you guys are going
to live but it's probably 95 is not an
unreasonable estimate and it might be
longer than that.
So because you know we're adding about
three months to the total lifespan every
year.
Right.
That's the rate of technological
improvement in relationship to overall
mortality.
So you know and that the degree to which
we're adding that extra.
LifeSpan is increasing each year.
You know and it may hit yet to the point
where we're increasing lifespan a year
every year.
Now I doubt it because it probably is.
It will probably be in a asymptote but.
It has been increasing for a very long
period of time.
So you know.
It's one thing to think about the
maximization of day to day freedom when
you're between say 15.
And 40 45 after that.
That's a whole different story.
And but modern people never think about
the last half of their life.
No soul.
Why.
I don't know but maybe they're afraid to
or something.